Cool, let's take a look at a solution to the parsing
CSV files exercise. We're going to begin here by opening the file. The
next thing to note is that we're going to read the first
line of that file, and split it using the common character as
the delimiter. This will give us a list of values that
we can use as keys for each one of the data items
that we pull out of this file later on. Okay, we're
then going to loop through the lines of the file. We'll break out
of this loop once we've processed ten lines. For every
line up to that, we're going to split the line, again using
the comma as the delimiter, and then we're going to initialize this
empty dictionary. Now, the entry each time through is going to
be this data item that we'll construct using the keys
that we got from the first line of the file, and
the individual field values that we just got here. We going to
loop through the fields and using enumerate, we'll get a index
value in addition to the value for each item
in this field's list. That would allow us to access
the appropriate value in the header to use as
a key for that particular field in our entry or
data item. And then we'll use the corresponding value
as the value for that particular field. Now note that
in both cases we're using the strip method here
in here in order to pull off any extraneous white-space
around either the header value or the individual value for
this line of the file. This is our first example
of data cleaning which is another major theme of this
course. In Excel files or .CSV files, a lot of times
you'll have Garbage white space that surround values. You don't
really notice them or care about them in the file
itself. But, when you're processing them in Python, they can
make a big difference especially if you're doing comparisons between values.
So, it's always a good idea to use strip. Okay,
finally, we're going to append that one data item to
our data array. So that it's included in the list
of items that we return from this function first file.